new year's eve just one day away can you
believe it
health officials are sounding the alarm
about large gatherings to ring in 2021
and their warnings come as the famous
ball drop right here in times square and
many other big celebrations like it
are going to be virtual this year but as
nikki batiste shows us gatherings at
home and other places could
accelerate the spread of covet 19.
confetti falling revelers cheering and
midnight kisses
ringing in the new year is always one
big party around the globe
but this year's celebrations will strike
a different
court as covid19 infections reach record
numbers
daily as we approach new year's eve and
new year's day
we cannot let our guard down according
to aaa as many as 84.5 million americans
were expected to travel from december
23rd to january third
to celebrate the holidays and the new
year leading to fears that new year's
parties will likely
amplify the spread it would be magical
thinking to think we're not going to see
a bump
after all this travel around the holiday
season with christmas and new year's
dr john lapook is among many health
officials concerned about
large gatherings violating coronavirus
protocols
to the people that say i have 10 friends
coming over but everyone tested
negative we're safe what do you say
the biggest misconception of this
pandemic and there's not even a close
second
is that i got tested today and therefore
i'm safe tomorrow or the next day
remember
that the incubation period is 2-14 days
law enforcement is already
tamping down on large gatherings in
newark new jersey this weekend
two women were arrested for hosting 200
people
at a makeshift indoor bar at a warehouse
at the famous la scala restaurant in
beverly hills california
customers reported an upcoming new
year's eve secret indoor party to
authorities
the restaurant responded to backlash
writing its invitation was
misunderstood and that they have
consistently taken the most drastic
steps to ensure
guest and employee safety but
invitations like this one promoting a
party in san francisco
are common across the united states how
concerned are you
and your department about public
gatherings or house parties on new
year's eve
we're very concerned san francisco
police are warning of penalties for
those breaking the state's rules
the protocol has been to admonish
someone or admonish people giving them
a warning at first sometimes
there isn't that chance to admonish
someone and
we will issue a citation it's possible
to be arrested
even it is yes
more than one million people usually
fill these times square streets to watch
the crystal ball drop but this year
they're closed to the public
dr lapook gave us some tips as we head
into new year's eve
do not party with anyone outside your
pod and even if you have been vaccinated
that does not mean the people around you
are safe from covet 19. adriana
such a good point nikki i mean
especially now that the variant in the
uk that's more contagious
is here in the u.s we really can't
gather even small gatherings and
remember just because you get the
vaccine
it doesn't mean you can't get the
coronavirus i talked to a doctor here in
new york city last night
who tested positive five days after he
got the vaccine
so it's just that he didn't get it sick
because of the protection correct the
vaccine ensures that you won't get
critically ill
and you won't die from it it'll be a
zoom party for me
yeah a zoom party all right i'll join
let me know send me the invite